Transcriber: Dalia Safar
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
العالم كله وأفلام الخيال العلمي،
حصرت الإنسان الآلي والذكاء الاصطناعي
دائمًا في أدوار الشر.
القصة المعتادة هي أن الإنسان الآلي دائمًا
سيصنع جيوشًا وسيهاجمنا بعد ذلك.
وأنه مع التطور التقني،
دور الإنسان سيبدأ في الانحصار.
في بداية 2020،
ظهر شبح مخيف بالنسبة لنا كلنا،
وهو كوفيد-19.
الوقت الذي كنا نخاف فيه أن نلمس أي شيء،
لأنه قد يكون ملوثًا بالفيروس.
وكان الكحول لا يفارق أيادينا.
مع تساقط الأطقم الطبية
بسبب الاحتكاك المباشر بينهم وبين المرضى.
ماذا تظنون كان الحل في ذلك الوقت؟
صحيح، كان الحل التقني.
كيف نستطيع القيام بشيء،
من شأنه أن يقلل الاحتكاك
ما بين الأطقم الطبية،
وتحميهم من هذه الخطورة.
وطبعًا كانت كيرا،
كيرا كان أول إنسان آلي في العالم
يأخد مسحات تفاعل البوليمراز المتسلسل/ PCR،
ولذلك العالم كله أشاد به.
منهم الأمم المتحدة التي صنفته من أفضل
50 ابتكار في مواجهة كوفيد-19.
وحسب مجلة فوربس من أفضل 100 اختراع
على مستوى العالم لمواجهة كوفيد-19.
وحسب رويترز وضعته من أفضل
20 إنسان آلي طبي على مستوى العالم.
(تصفيق)
بعد ذلك عملتُ على تطويره [غير واضح]،
وصنعت ما يسمى الإصدار الثالث،
الذي يقدرُ أن يعمل إشعاعات لحوالي 90%
من الفحوصات السريرية
التي يستطيع أن يقوم فيها الطبيب.
وبعد ذلك حصلت على جائزة جنيف للاختراعات
عام 2021 في [غير واضح].
(تصفيق)
في مشروع التشخيص الطب المبّكر
بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي.
هنا،
جئنا إلى السنوات الأخيرة،
كان هناك خطر كبير جدًا يقترب منّا،
مع تغير المناخ ومع الزيادة السكانية،
بدأ نصيب الفرد من المياه يقل.
هل يعرف أحد ما هو مقدار
نصيب الفرد في مصر حاليًا؟
250 مترًا مكعبًا سنويًا
نصيب الفرد من المياه.
مع أن خط الفقر المائي
حسب تقديرات الأمم المتحدة
هو 1000 متر مكعب سنويًا للفرد.
فنحن تقريبًا 25% من الحد الأدنى
الذي من المفترض أن يكون نصيبنا من المياه.
حسنًا، فكرت كيف أعمل حلًا مستدامًا،
يكون بعيدًا عن المصادر الطبيعية
لمياه الشرب الطبيعية،
مثل الأنهار والآبار العذبة
كيف أقدرُ على فك شفرة
الحضارة المصرية منذ آلاف السنين،
الذي هو ارتباط الإنسان دائمًا
بمصادر المياه الطبيعية
وأكبر مثال على ذلك هو الدلتا ونهر النيل.
دائمًا ومن سبع آلاف سنة،
يوجد السكان حول الدلتا ونهر النيل.
وطبعًا حتى أقدر عمل الحل المستدام هذا،
واجهني تحديين:
أول تحدي، كيف أصنع مصدر
مياه نقي وبأقل التكاليف.
التحدي الثاني، كيف أقدر على عمل ذلك
في أصعب الظروف الممكنة.
وكيف أقدر على عمله أيضًا
في أقل نسبة رطوبة.
بحيث أقدر عمل ذلك في الصحراء.
طبعًا،
أخذتُ كوكب المريخ كمثال،
أو بدأت العمل على أساس ظروف كوكب المريخ.
وكلنا يعرف أن ظروف كوكب المريخ من الضغط،
ودرجة الحرارة التي هي أقل
من 50 درجة مئوية.
وأيضًا نسبة ثنائي أكسيد
الكربون العالية جدًا.
ومن هنا جاء إيلو/ELU.
طبعًا، عندما بدأت في إيلو،
بدأت في عمل نظام محاكاه
لنفس ظروف الطقس الموجودة في المريخ:
من نسبة الغازات وثنائي أكسيد الكربون
والضغط ودرجة الحرارة وكل شيء تقريبًا.
وبدأت في عمل نظام المحاكاة هذا،
وكان العامل الأساسي في الموضوع
الذي يقدر على عمل نسبة تكيف
ما بين هذا النظام الداخلي والبيئة المحيطة،
هو تعلّم الآلة أو الذكاء الاصطناعي،
أو الشبكات العصبية الاصطناعية
حتى أقدر على عمل ذلك بكل سهولة.
وحيث أقدرُ على الوصول إلى درجة التكثف،
ودرجة التكثف هي الدرجة التي يتحول
عندها الغاز إلى ماء سائل.
كيف أقدر على عمل ذلك
في هذه الظروف المحيطة؟
بالفعل، عملتُ بعض التجارب كثيرًا،
نجحت بالفعل أن أقدر على عمل ذلك
في نفس هذه الظروف.
بدأت في عمل تجربة الإنسان الآلي إيلو.
يعتبر إيلو أول إنسان آلي في العالم،
يمكنه عمل حياة مستدامة
على كوكب المريخ،
أو يولد مياه على كوكب المريخ.
طبعًا،
أنا من هنا بدأت أن أحصل
على مصدر للحياة،
أو مصدر للمياه مستدام يؤمن المستقبل،
أو يؤمن نصيب الفرد من مياه الشرب.
في سنة 2050، متوقع حدوث شح في المياه،
خصوصا في منطقة شمال أفريقيا
والشرق الأوسط .
حيث للأسف من الممكن
أن يتقاتل الناس من أجل المياه،
ومن الممكن أن يموت الناس بسبب قلة المياه.
اليوم، سأهديكم شيئًا،
هذه زجاجة إيلو
أو نموذج مبدأي لزجاجة إيلو،
هذه زجاجة تعيد ملء نفسها كل خمس ساعات،
تعطي تأمين،
لنسبة المياه اليومية للفرد.
بحيث لو أنني طالب في المدرسة، ستكون معي.
كذلك أفراد الجيش،
وكل فرد.
لقد بدأنا فعلًا في تنفيذها،
وأتمنى العام القادم
أن تكون هذه الزجاجة في يد كل شخص.
(تصفيق)
طبعًا مع كل الأشياء التي تُعمل،
أو التي نحاول أن نعملها،
نحاول دائمًا أن كل شخص يفيد،
أو يبحث عن أفكار جديدة يفيد البشرية بها،
سواء في تخصصي، أنا مهندس،
سواء في تخصصات حضراتكم،
أو أي تخصص تقدرون فيها إفادة البشرية.
وهذا هو الهدف الذي أتيتُ به إليكم اليوم.
شكرًا!
(تصفيق)